i think uh chin lied to us and he took
that man up on his offer because this is
a commercial that someone sent in for
cats in the wild
he got his gig give your business that's
it that's it
it's really all leading up to one that
cat's wild right there that's fantastic
but that looks like him it really does
chin uh it's a little bit there
a little bit the nose he has those
gauges those like i used to have those
too though yeah
you did yeah you used to have gauges
chin yeah but not huge but it was like
you know those the silver ones yeah damn
daddy oh yeah are your ears still [ __ ]
up from it because i didn't keep it in
forever
so they're not [ __ ] up no no they're
not [ __ ] up
got it someone saw theo playing cricket
picking up a new sport oh
what's that starbucks snickerdoodle
ordering food
yeah the qriket once sucked it really
was all the lead up to this starbucks
one
uh this is easily the most we've ever
sent in
of uh cats in the wild brendan is doing
a little moonlighting what are you doing
going after his passions
[Music]
it looks like he took the business card
and really ran with the opportunities
we're going to mix that up and we're
going to add our ice cubes to top it up
here's the deal you could just stop did
brian monarch make this
dude his hair is dope man i'm on my way
you're just
talking about getting that hair dude
this guy's my
[Laughter]
that's gonna be me in five years
working that star i'll just say this
that guy's ordered
more than a that guy's had more than a
double shot on his back
[Laughter]
you guys are disgusting
can i have some
[Laughter]
again your guy seems cool man i still
don't have an issue with this dog
all right he was he was adding on to
your joke man bro here's what the crazy
thing i said marilyn manson a minute ago
yeah richard langenstein took us to a
marilyn manson's concert
when i was probably 13 or 14 years old
dude who's cooking your steaks take you
to a concert too
took us to marilyn manson's concert bro
and like good tickets a place as big as
two of these offices man real small it
was a great time oh it was insane
the beautiful people the beautiful i've
seen them live
he's creepy though huh should i be
worried theo took me to an aerosmith
concert
just us
grabbed your hand when the armageddon
song came on
i don't want to code it was good nick
wasn't really into it
no i loved i loved it uh during that
song though stephen tyler tried to like
hold the mic
out towards theo and theo was away
texting on his phone oh no
pissed off stephen tyler oh no
on [ __ ] real dude dude i was singing
the whole time to the one
time you looked down i go down i tried
to get some girl's phone number who was
an escort obviously with some older man
and i drugged her and she passed out
what happened wait what wait why didn't
you say that
this is the best night ever some guy
next to us had two women then i guess he
over drugged one of them or something
and she just
passed out bro
[Laughter]
it's sad too man yeah that guy's down a
party man man that sounds like a good
night though did you guys get some
steaks
dude and i just got like five digits of
her number before she passed all the way
out
the saddest part she's a cool girl
she was attractive she was she looks
smart she's smart yeah
what check out the big brain on brad